oui bienvenue parole autochtone si c'est
melissa maulin dupuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question de bryant qui me
demande pourquoi plusieurs nations
autochtones ne veulent pas de marijuana
ou d'alcool dans leur communauté
pour commencer mais je dois avouer que
c'est une question qui est extrêmement
difficile au niveau national mais aussi
au niveau historique parce que l'alcool
la consommation d'alcool la consommation
de drogue est lié très souvent un abus
de l'alcool un abus des drogues et ça
c'est en lien très direct avec les
pensionnats indiens aussi directe avec
la sédentarisation forcée dans les
réserves mais aussi avec l'historique
des premiers contacts ou certains biens
de très grande valeur et échanger contre
de petites bouteilles d'alcool qui
valait même pas ce que les fourreurs par
exemple valait donc cet historique de
cette fête à voir à travers l'alcool ou
d'utiliser l'alcool pour éponger la
douleur vécue par les pensionnats avec
elle une très mauvaise réputation et on
a vu l'apparition des réserves sèche où
les communautés sèche
là où la loi sur des idées permettent
justement de dire qu'est ce qu'on veut
que ce qu'on veut pas dans la réserve on
a interdit la vente et la possession
d'alcool dans les communautés et c'est
la même chose pour la marijuana mais
depuis la légalisation
c'est très compliqué par exemple parce
que pas tout le monde
une relation négative à l'alcool pas
tout le monde a une relation négative à
la marijuana
certaines personnes même la nouvelle
génération ont réussi à guérir beaucoup
les traumatismes liés aux pensionnats et
une consommation
quand je dirais équilibré avec ses
produits cependant avec nos aînés nos
parents même moi j'ai une
vision beaucoup plus problématique avec
l'alcool la drogue
donc oui on va comprendre pourquoi
certains communauté vont pas vouloir que
ça soit ça accèdent à leurs jeunes à
leurs enfants et vont garder les
communautés sèche donc c'est encore une
problématique qui est lié à une guérison
qui est en cours et je voudrais te
remercions de poser des questions mais
vous pouvez aussi consulter demander à
des gens qui sont dans les communautés
de pouvoir vous parler de leur
historique et souvent ça va revenir
l'historique des pensionnats n'hésitez
pas à leur poser des questions n'hésitez
pas à nous envoyer des questions et
partager cette vidéo je souhaite une
belle semaine